Hey there, Shankar here. Over the next few weeks, we're going to bring you a series of stories exploring how race, immigration, and religion intersect with politics, policing, and the media. We begin today with an episode from last fall that explored the broken windows theory of policing and how that theory became widely popular in ways its creators never intended. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vidantam. In the early 1980s, a couple of researchers wrote an article in The Atlantic that would have far-reaching consequences. The article introduced a new idea about crime and policing.
大家好，我是香卡。在接下来的几周里，我们将为您带来一系列报道，探讨种族、移民和宗教如何与政治、警务以及媒体交织在一起。今天我们从去年秋天的一集节目开始，该节目探讨了警务中的“破窗理论”，以及该理论是如何以其创造者从未预料到的方式广泛普及的。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。在20世纪80年代初，《大西洋月刊》上发表了一篇由两位研究人员撰写的文章，这产生了深远的影响。这篇文章引入了一个关于犯罪和警务的新观点。
It was called Broken Windows. The idea was simple. A broken window is a sign of a neglected community. And a neglected community is a place where crime can thrive. The researchers said if police could fix the small problems, the big ones would disappear. So the Broken Windows theory was this magical solution that basically everybody could like. It quickly became seen as a panacea for crime. Today we explore how ideas sometimes get away from those who invented them, and then are taken to places that were never intended.
它被称为“破窗”。这个想法很简单。一扇破了的窗户是一个社区遭到忽视的标志。而一个遭到忽视的社区则是犯罪可以滋生的地方。研究人员表示，如果警方能够解决小问题，大问题就会消失。因此，“破窗理论”是一个基本上所有人都会喜欢的神奇解决方案。它很快被视为治理犯罪的灵丹妙药。今天，我们探讨观点有时是如何脱离其发明者，然后被带到从未预料到的地方的。
It's a beautiful story and it's a myth. Our story begins in 1969. The psychologist Philip Zimbado ran an interesting experiment. He abandoned two cars on the street, one in a mostly poor, crime-ridden section of the Bronx in New York City, and the other in an afloen neighborhood in Palo Alto, California. Both cars were left without license plates, parked with the hoods up. With 10 minutes of leaving the car in the Bronx, Passersby began taking things of value. The car was quickly stripped for parts.
这是一个美丽的故事，也是一个神话。我们的故事始于1969年。心理学家菲利普·津巴多进行了一项有趣的实验。他在街头遗弃了两辆汽车，一辆在纽约市布朗克斯区一个主要贫困、犯罪猖獗的街区，另一辆在加利福尼亚州帕洛阿尔托一个富裕的街区。这两辆车都没有挂车牌，引擎盖都开着。在把车留在布朗克斯后的10分钟内，路人就开始拿走有价值的东西。这辆车很快就被拆光了零件。
Then, the random destruction began. Windows were smashed. The car was destroyed. But for more than a week in Palo Alto, the other car remained untouched. Until Zombardo himself gave the car a smash with a sledgehammer. And once the car was damaged, it became fair game. This is George L. Kelling.
然后，随意的破坏开始了。车窗被砸碎。汽车被毁坏。但在帕洛阿尔托，另一辆车在一个多星期里完好无损，直到津巴多本人用大锤砸了这辆车。一旦汽车遭到损坏，它就成了人人可欺的目标。这是乔治·L·凯林。
He's a senior fellow at the Manhattan Institute. In 1982, I co-authored an article called Broken Windows with James Cue Wilson. This article has gotten considerable attention in the policing and non-policing world. George was fascinated by what had happened in Palo Alto. Once the car was damaged, things played out exactly as they had in the Bronx. The idea that once disorder begins, it doesn't matter what the neighborhood is, things can begin to get out of control. George reason that the same thing might be true for communities as a whole.
他是曼哈顿研究所的高级研究员。1982年，我和詹姆斯·奎因·威尔逊合著了一篇名为《破窗》的文章。这篇文章在警务和非警务界引起了相当大的关注。乔治对帕洛阿尔托发生的事情着迷。一旦汽车遭到损坏，事情的发展就和在布朗克斯一模一样。这种观点认为，一旦混乱开始，无论是什么社区，事情都可能开始失控。乔治推断，整个社区可能也是如此。
A broken window in a neighborhood sends the signal that the neighborhood is uncared for. So if police departments address the little crimes and misdemeanors that might create visible signs of disorder, maybe, just maybe, the bigger stuff wouldn't happen either. Once you begin to deal with the small problems in neighborhoods, you begin to empower those neighborhoods, and people claim their public spaces, and store owners extend their concerns to what happened on the streets, residents control park spaces, communities get strengthened,
社区里的一扇破窗户发出了这样一个信号：这个社区无人照管。因此，如果警察部门处理那些可能造成明显混乱迹象的小犯罪和轻罪，也许，仅仅是也许，更大的事情也不会发生了。一旦你开始处理社区中的小问题，你就会开始赋予这些社区权力，人们就会重新宣称他们对公共空间的权利，店主们会将他们的关切延伸到街道上发生的事情，居民们管理公园空间，社区得到加强，
once order is restored or maintained and it is that dynamic that helps to prevent crime. This wasn't what many police departments were doing. Officers were focused on solving major crimes. Georgianist co-author suggested police departments ought to change their focus. They ought to clean up the streets, keep people from smoking pot and public, crack down on subway fairbeaters. As it turned out, this was exactly what many communities wanted. If right now we were to go to some neighborhood meeting about problems in the neighborhood, at least three and probably four of those will be problems of disorder, and that is, use taking over a park,
一旦秩序得以恢复或维护，正是这种动态机制有助于预防犯罪。这并不是许多警察部门当时在做的事情。警官们的重点是破获重案。乔治和他的合著者建议警察部门应该改变他们的重点。他们应该整顿街道，阻止人们在公共场合抽麻，打击地铁逃票行为。事实证明，这正是许多社区想要的。如果现在我们去参加某个关于社区问题的社区会议，其中至少有三个、很可能是四个会是关于混乱的问题，也就是说，青少年占领公园，
prostitutes hustling fathers and front of their children, drug dealers hanging around corners. Those are the kinds of things that comprise a good share of the calls that come to police departments and the demand that's based on police to do something about these problems. BELL RINGS The argument came at an opportune time. based on police to do something about these problems. The argument came at an opportune time. This was a period of high crime and high incarceration,
妓女在孩子面前拉拢父亲，毒贩在街角闲逛。这些正是构成打给警察部门的大部分电话以及基于警察对这些问题采取行动的要求的那类事情。钟声响起 这个论点出现得很是时候。基于警察对这些问题采取行动的要求。这个论点出现得很是时候。这是一个高犯罪率和高监禁率的时期，
and it seemed as if there was no way out of that dynamic, and it seemed as if there was no way out of just filling prisons as a way to address the crime problem. This is Bernhard Hartcourt, professor of law at Columbia University. As policy makers was scrambling for answers to crime, a new mayor in New York came to power offering a solution. Ladies and gentlemen, the mayor of the city of New York, Rudolf W. Giuliani. Rudy Giuliani won election in 1993, promising to reduce crime and clean up the streets. Very quickly, he adopted broken windows as his mantra.
而且似乎没有办法摆脱这种动态，似乎除了用填满监狱的方式来解决犯罪问题之外，别无他路。这是哥伦比亚大学法学教授伯恩哈德·哈考特。正当决策者们争先恐后地寻找打击犯罪的答案时，纽约的一位新市长带着解决方案上台了。女士们先生们，纽约市市长鲁道夫·W·朱利安尼。鲁迪·朱利安尼在1993年赢得选举，承诺减少犯罪并整顿街道。很快，他将“破窗”采纳为他的口号。
It was one of those rare ideas that appealed to people on both sides of the aisle. Consovatives liked the policy because it meant restoring order, and liberals liked it, Bernard says, because it seemed like an enlightened way to prevent crime. All of a sudden, it seems as if, well, instead of throwing people in prison and cracking down, all you really had to do was just pick up the trash and get rid of a homeless person and fix an abandoned building, just these small forms of disorder. That course were pretty widespread in a city like New York. Rudy Giuliani and his new police commissioner William Bratton focused first on cleaning up the subway system.
这是一个罕见的能够吸引两党民众的想法。伯恩哈德说，保守派喜欢这个政策，因为它意味着恢复秩序；而自由派喜欢它，因为它看起来像是预防犯罪的一种开明方式。突然之间，似乎，好吧，与其把人们扔进监狱并进行镇压，不如说你真正需要做的只是捡起垃圾、赶走无家可归的人并修复一栋废弃的建筑物，仅仅是这些小型的混乱形式。这些在纽约这样的城市里相当普遍。鲁迪·朱利安尼和他的新警察局长威廉·布拉顿首先把重点放在清理地铁系统上。
George Kelly again. Here was a system that was entirely out of control. Writership was dropping. Lawlessness rained in the subway, and 250,000 people a day weren't being there fair. The Mayor and the Police Commissioner sent hundreds of police officers into the subway to crack down on turn-style jumpers and vandals. Very quickly, they found confirmation for their theory. Going off to petty crime led the police to violent criminals.
再次请出乔治·凯林。这是一个完全失控的系统。乘客量在下降。地铁里无法无天，每天有25万的人不买票。市长和警察局长派遣了数百名警察进入地铁，打击跳闸者和破坏者。很快，他们为自己的理论找到了证实。打击轻微犯罪引导警察找到了暴力罪犯。
In some station it was found that as many as one in ten people who were not paying the fare were either wanted on a warrant for a felony or were carrying an illegal weapon. Not all fare-beaters were criminals, but a lot of criminals were fair betas. It turns out that serious criminals are pretty busy. They commit minor offenses as well as major offenses. The policy was quickly scaled up from the subway system to the entire city of New York. Police ramped up Mr. Miner Arres for things like smoking marijuana and public, spraying graffiti, selling loose cigarettes. Almost instantly, they were able to trump
在某些车站，人们发现多达十分之一逃票的人要么是被通缉的重罪犯，要么身上携带非法武器。并非所有逃票者都是罪犯，但许多罪犯都是逃票者。事实证明，重罪犯相当忙碌。他们既犯轻罪，也犯重罪。这项政策很快从地铁系统推广到了整个纽约市。警方加大了对在公共场合抽大麻、喷涂涂鸦、兜售散装香烟等行为的轻罪逮捕力度。几乎瞬间，他们就能够夸耀
at their success. Crime was falling. The murder rate plummeted. It seemed like a miracle. The media loved the story. At first, people laughed when he launched a politeness campaign. We begin with sociologists George Kelly, and his ideas about how to reduce serious crime by restoring public ordering communities. It's called Broken Windows. Go after quality of life offenses to help reduce bigger crimes.
他们的成功。犯罪率在下降。谋杀率骤降。这看起来像个奇迹。媒体喜欢这个故事。起初，当他发起文明礼貌运动时，人们笑了。我们从社会学家乔治·凯林开始，以及他关于如何通过恢复社区公共秩序来减少严重犯罪的想法。这被称为“破窗”。打击生活质量犯罪以帮助减少更大的犯罪。
George Kelly and another researcher found what they believed was clear evidence of the success of broken windows. In neighborhoods where there was a sharp increase in misdemeanor arrests, suggesting broken windows policing was enforced, there was also a sharp decline in crime. By the time Rudy Giuliani was giving his farewell address at the end of 2001, broken windows had become one of his greatest accomplishments. The reality is that the model that was adopted for dealing with crime in New York City is the very, very best way to assure that you can keep a city safe. The mayor emphasized the beautiful and simple idea behind the success. The Broken Windows theory replaced the idea that we were too busy to pay attention to
乔治·凯林和另一位研究人员发现了他们认为能够证明“破窗”成功的清晰证据。在轻罪逮捕人数急剧增加（这表明“破窗警务”得到了执行）的社区，犯罪率也出现了急剧下降。到2001年底鲁迪·朱利安尼发表告别演说时，“破窗”已成为他最伟大的成就之一。现实情况是，为应对纽约市犯罪而采用的模式是确保能够保持城市安全的最好、最好的方法。市长强调了成功背后的美好而简单的想法。破窗理论取代了那种认为我们太忙而无暇关注
street level prostitution, too busy to pay attention to panhandling, too busy to pay attention to graffiti. Well, you can't be too busy to pay attention to those things, because those are the things that underlie the problems of crime that you have in your society. In less than a decade, New York was transformed. That's right. Yeah, everything's going well. If you're on the upper east side, but not hardcore again. Of course, it's going a lot less well if you're in other burrows or in other neighborhoods where all of the policing and all of the arrests are taking place.
街头卖淫的观点，太忙而无暇关注乞讨的观点，太忙而无暇关注涂鸦的观点。好吧，你不能太忙而无暇关注这些事情，因为这些正是你社会中存在的犯罪问题背后的根源。在不到十年的时间里，纽约发生了脱胎换骨的变化。没毛病。是的，一切都很顺利。如果你在上东区，但再次听听哈考特的看法。当然，如果你在其他行政区或其他正进行着所有警务和逮捕行动的社区，情况就没那么顺利了。
As broken windows policing was coming into force, some critics said it unfairly targeted communities of color. When we come back, we'll talk about this idea and a deeper problem. Broken Windows may not have been quite the raging success we thought it was. It's a very sugar-coated idea that would it be true, it would be marvelous. Stay with us.
随着“破窗警务”的实施，一些批评者表示，它不公平地针对有色人种社区。当我们回来时，我们将讨论这个想法和一个更深层的问题。破窗可能不像我们想象的那样是一场狂暴的成功。这是一个被严重糖衣包装的想法，如果它是真的，那将是奇妙的。请继续收听。
The rise of broken windows policing and the dramatic fall and crime made for a beautiful story. But right from the start, there was signs something was wrong with the beautiful narrative. Crime was starting to go down in New York prior to the Giuliani election and prior to the implementation of broken windows policing. And of course, what we witnessed from that period, and it's basically from about 91 that crime in the country starts going down, is a remarkable, remarkable drop in violent crime in this country.
“破窗警务”的兴起和犯罪率的急剧下降构成了一个美好的故事。但从一开始，就有迹象表明这个美好的叙事出了问题。在朱利安尼当选之前和“破窗警务”实施之前，纽约的犯罪率就已经开始下降了。当然，我们从那个时期（基本上是从大约91年开始，全国犯罪率开始下降）所目睹的，是这个国家暴力犯罪显著、显著的下降。
Now, what's so remarkable about it is how widespread it was. So widespread, in fact, that crime dropped not only in New York, but in many other cities where nothing like broken windows policing was in place. In fact, crime even fell in parts of the country where police departments were mired in corruption scandals and largely seen as dysfunctional. Los Angeles was racked with terrible policing problems during the whole time. In fact, the period is a book ended on one side by the Rodney King scandal, and on the other side by the Ramparts scandal. In between the two, the LAPD is pretty much
现在，最引人注目的是它的普及程度。事实上，它的普及程度如此之高，以至于犯罪率不仅在纽约下降，在许多其他根本没有实施类似“破窗警务”的城市也在下降。事实上，犯罪率甚至在该国那些陷入腐败丑闻且被广泛视为运转失常的警察部门所在的地区也有所下降。洛杉矶在整个期间都饱受可怕的警务问题的困扰。事实上，这段时期的两端分别被罗德尼·金丑闻和兰帕特丑闻所夹。在这两者之间，洛杉矶警察局基本上是
dysfunctional, and despite the fact that the LAPD isn't doing anything, basically, I mean it's been, it's certainly not doing broken windows policing, crime drops as much in Los Angeles as it does in New York. How could this be? Well, there are many theories. Some attribute the nationwide drop in crime to the growing economy, the end of the crack cocaine epidemic, even environmental factors. Some criminologists credit harsher sentencing guidelines. In 2006, Bernard Harcourt reviewed the study George Kelly had conducted in 2001. The earlier study had powerfully made the case that broken windows policing worked. It found that the areas that saw the largest number of misdemeanor arrests also had the
运转失常的，尽管洛杉矶警察局基本上什么也没做，我是说它一直、它肯定没有在做破窗警务，但洛杉矶的犯罪率下降幅度与纽约一样大。这怎么可能呢？嗯，有很多理论。一些人将全国范围内犯罪率的下降归因于不断增长的经济、快克可卡因流行病的结束，甚至是环境因素。一些犯罪学家将其归功于更严厉的量刑准则。2006年，伯恩哈德·哈考特审查了乔治·凯林在2001年进行的研究。早期研究强有力地证明了“破窗警务”是有效的。它发现轻罪逮捕人数最多的地区，暴力犯罪的下降幅度也最大。
biggest drops in violent crime. But it turned out that actually he had failed to include in his study a very common explanation which is called a reversion to the mean. And it's something that's well known in the stock market. But basically the idea is, you know, if something goes up a lot, it tends to go down a lot. A graph in George Kelly's 2001 paper is revealing. It shows the crime rate falling dramatically in the early 1990s, but this window of time gives us its selective picture. Right before this decline came a spike in crime. And if you go further back, you see a series of spikes and declines. And each time, the bigger a spike, the bigger the decline that follows, as crime reverts to the mean.
但事实证明，实际上他在研究中未能纳入一个非常普遍的解释，被称为“均值回归”。这是股票市场中广为人知的事情。但基本上这个想法是，你知道，如果某样东西涨得很多，它往往会跌得很多。乔治·凯林2001年论文中的一张图表很有启发性。它显示犯罪率在20世纪90年代初急剧下降，但这段时间窗口给我们提供了一幅有选择性的画面。就在这次下降之前，犯罪率出现了飙升。如果你再往前看，你会看到一系列的飙升和下降。每一次，飙升越大，随后的下降也就越大，因为犯罪率会回归均值。
George Kelly acknowledges that broken windows may not have had a dramatic effect on crime. But he still thinks it has value. Even if broken windows did not have a substantial impact on crime, order is an end in itself in a cosmopolitan, diverse world. Strangers have to feel comfortable moving through communities for those communities to thrive. Order is an end in itself and it doesn't need the justification of serious crime. But it's worth noting that this was not the premise on which the theory was sold. Broken
乔治·凯林承认，“破窗”可能对犯罪没有产生巨大的影响。但他仍然认为它有价值。即使“破窗”对犯罪没有产生实质性影响，在一个国际化、多元化的世界里，秩序本身就是目的。陌生人必须感到在社区中穿行是舒适的，这些社区才能繁荣发展。秩序本身就是目的，它不需要严重犯罪作为正义性证明。但值得注意的是，这不是该理论出售的前提。破窗
Windows policing was advertised as an innovative way to control violent crime, not just a way to get panhandlers and prostitutes off the streets. There was also another big problem with broken windows. Here's Bernhard Hartcourt again. We immediately saw an increase, a sharp increase in complaints of police misconduct. And that's actually one of the most interesting things about the period, really, from 1993 to 96, for instance, when Giuliani is implementing the Quality of Life Initiative. We always associate it with greater order, because crime drops 60%, but complaints of police misconduct increased by 60%.
警务被宣传为控制暴力犯罪的创新方式，而不仅仅是将乞丐和妓女赶出街头的办法。“破窗”还有另一个大问题。再次请出伯恩哈德·哈考特。我们立刻看到了投诉量的增加，对警察不当行为投诉的急剧增加。事实上，这是这段时期最有趣的事情之一，例如从1993年到96年，当朱利安尼正在实施生活质量倡议时。我们总是把它与更大的秩序联系在一起，因为犯罪率下降了60%，但对警察不当行为的投诉却增加了60%。
You might wonder, well, actually, was it a period of greater order, or was it a period of greater disorder? Of course, this reflects the fact that the notion of orderliness is itself constructed by us and by what we focus on. But if you focus on police civilian relations starting in 1993, what you're going to see is a tremendous amount of disorder that erupts as a result of broken windows policing. With complaints skyrocketing, with settlements of police misconduct cases, skyrocketing, and of course with incidents, brutal incidents, all sudden happening at a faster and faster clip.
你可能会想，好吧，实际上，那是一个秩序更好的时期，还是一个混乱更多的时期？当然，这反映了一个事实，即秩序的概念本身是由我们以及我们的关注点所构建的。但是，如果你从1993年开始关注警察与平民的关系，你将看到的是，由于“破窗警务”而爆发的大量混乱。投诉量飙升，警察不当行为案件的和解金飙升，当然还有事件，残酷的事件，突然以越来越快的速度发生。
The problem intensified with a new practice that grew out of broken windows. It was called stop and Frisk. It was embraced in New York City after Mayor Michael Bloomberg won election in 2001. If Broken Windows meant arresting people for misdemeanors in hopes of preventing more serious crimes, Stop and Frisk said, why even wait for the misdemeanor? Why not go ahead and stop? Question, search.
随着一项从“破窗”中衍生出来的新做法，这个问题加剧了。它被称为“拦截搜身”。在迈克尔·布隆伯格市长于2001年赢得选举后，它在纽约市得到了采纳。如果“破窗”意味着为了预防更严重的犯罪而逮捕轻罪人员，“拦截搜身”则说，为什么还要等轻罪发生？为什么不直接进行拦截？盘问、搜查。
Anyone who looks suspicious. Once Bloomberg became mayor, he turned from a policy of high misdemeanor arrests to a policy of stop and frisk. They substitute for each other because both of them provide something to the police
任何看起来可疑的人。一旦布隆伯格成为市长，他就从高轻罪逮捕政策转向了拦截搜身政策。它们相互替代，因为这两者都为警察提供了一些
that the police feels is necessary, which is to be able to come up to an individual, ask them questions, do some kind of a search, whether it's a pat down or a full search upon arrest, possibly do a records check, check for warrants, et cetera. And so what it does is it gets a lot more information to the police, you make more informants, you can get fingerprints and those things are from a policing
警察认为必要的东西，那就是能够走近一个人，向他们提问，进行某种搜查（无论是拍身搜查还是逮捕时的全面搜查），可能进行记录检查，检查是否有未执行的逮捕令等。因此，它为警察带来了更多的信息，你制造了更多的线索提供者，你可以获得指纹，从警务的角度来看，
perspective, those things are always going to be useful. There were high profile cases where misdemeanor arrests are stopping and questioning did lead to information that helps solve much more serious crimes, even homicides. But there were many, many more cases where the police stops turned up nothing. In 2008, police made nearly 250,000 stops in New York for what they called, furtive movements. The police did find guns during these stops, but the numbers might surprise you. Only one-fifteenth of one percent turned up a gun. Police did find guns during these stops, but the numbers might surprise you.
这些事情将永远是有用的。确实存在一些引人注目的案件，轻罪逮捕或拦截盘问确实带来了有助于破获更严重犯罪（甚至是凶杀案）的信息。但有更多、更多的案件中，警察的拦截一无所获。2008年，警察在纽约以他们所谓的“鬼祟动作”为由进行了近25万次拦截。警察确实在这些拦截中找到了枪支，但这个数字可能会让你感到惊讶。只有十五分之一的百分之一搜出了枪支。警察确实在这些拦截中找到了枪支，但这个数字可能会让你感到惊讶。
Only one-fifteenth of one percent turned up a gun. Even more problematic, in order to be able to go after disorder, you have to be able to define it. Is it a trash bag covering a broken window? Teenagers on a street corner playing music too loudly? In Chicago, the researchers Robert Samson and Steven Routenbush analyzed what makes people perceive social disorder. They found that if two neighborhoods had exactly the same amount of graffiti and litter and loitering, people saw more disorder, more broken windows, in neighborhoods with more African
只有十五分之一的百分之一搜出了枪支。更具问题的是，为了打击混乱，你必须能够定义它。是盖着破窗户的垃圾袋吗？是在街角音乐放得太大声的青少年吗？在芝加哥，研究人员罗伯特·桑姆森和史蒂芬·鲁滕布什分析了是什么让人感知到社会混乱。他们发现，如果两个社区有完全相同数量的涂鸦、垃圾和闲逛，人们会在有更多非裔美国人的社区看到更多的混乱、更多的破窗户。
Americans. It was, I think, a Wednesday or Thursday night. I was coming home from dinner with a friend. This is Jamal Johnson. He's African American, 40 years old. I'd noticed that it increased police presence in the neighborhood. Because after we had dinner, we literally came across something like nine or ten different cops in about a three-blocked radius.
我想那是星期三或星期四的晚上。我和一个朋友吃完晚饭正走在回家的路上。这是贾马尔·约翰逊。他是非裔美国人，40岁。我注意到社区里的警察存在感增加了。因为我们吃完晚饭后，在大概三个街区的半径内，我们真的遇到了大约九到十个不同的警察。
Jamal was walking with his friend, but eventually the two split off. And as I was walking on a street I noticed the cops looking at us, but not really paying us much attention after the initial sort of scan. And then as I rounded the corner to my block, there was a police officer on the corner and at that stage I was by myself and of course at that stage I got stopped. Jemal was carrying a small utility knife. He was a filmmaker and it came in handy on set. I had come from a day of work and I was working on a photo shoot and a police officer noticed that I had had my work knife which I know to be street
贾马尔和他的朋友在走着，但最终两人分开了。当我在一条街上走时，我注意到警察在看我们，但在最初的某种扫描之后并没有太关注我们。然后当我拐弯走向我所在的街区时，街角有一个警察，在那时我孤身一人，当然在那时我被拦下了。贾马尔随身携带一把小型多功能刀。他是一名电影制作人，这在片场很派上用场。我刚结束一天的摄影工作，一名警察注意到我带着工作刀，我知道这在街头是合法的，但他让我把它拿出来并向他展示，然后他向我要了我的身份证。
legal but which he sort of asked me to take out and and show to him and then he asked me for my ID. He then called him a dispatch once he'd had my ID. He asked me some basic questions about where I lived, what my job was, what I was doing with it with my evening and so forth. And when he couldn't reach a dispatch, he then started to take down my information, at which stage I said to him,
拿到我的身份证后，他呼叫了调度中心。他问了我一些基本问题，比如我住在哪里，我的工作是什么，我这个晚上在做什么等等。当他联系不上调度中心时，他开始记录我的信息，在这个阶段我对他说，
please don't put me in a system, you know that I live right here. And he also known my knife, my knife is legal, at which point he said that the knife wasn't in fact legal. And then he asked me if I wanted to, if I preferred to go to jail. To which I said, I think you can understand why I wouldn't like to be in the system. I also think you know that I don't want to go to jail tonight. At which point he said, well, don't give me a hard time. My response was, excuse me sir, I certainly didn't mean to do that. Thank you. At which stage he took down my info, told me not to have my knife on me again and then let me go home with a sort of a sour look.
请不要把我录入系统，你知道我就住在这里。他也知道我的刀，我的刀是合法的，此时他说这把刀事实上并不合法。然后他问我想不想，我是说我是否愿意去局子。对此我说，我想你能理解为什么我不想进系统。我也认为你知道我今晚不想去局子。此时他说，好吧，别给我找麻烦。我的回应是，对不起，先生，我绝对不是那个意思。谢谢。在这个阶段他记下了我的信息，告诉我以后不要随身携带这把刀，然后带着一种难看的脸色让我回家。
I think it's worse than humiliation to me because it's not personal. And to me that's worse because when your society can detain you, won't let you speak to them, you know, like in the sense that the guy said, you know, essentially why are you talking back to me? When that becomes your relationship with your society, that means that your life or the very least like your livelihood that you're getting to and from work is that question. So I don't really necessarily need to feel huge, huge moment to pride from every, from every interaction I have with the police, but I certainly need to feel that my life or, or, or even, or even my evening and my, my police record isn't in danger, just arbitrarily. So that feeling of an impersonal, not friendly government standing
我认为这对我来说比羞辱还要糟糕，因为它不是针对个人的。对我来说这更糟，因为当你的社会可以拘留你、不让你跟他们说话（就像那家伙说的那样，你知道的，基本上是“你为什么顶嘴？”），当这成为你与社会的关系时，这就意味着你的生活，或者至少是你上班下班的生计，受到了质疑。所以我真的不一定需要从与警察的每一次互动中感受到巨大的骄傲感，但我绝对需要感觉到我的生活，或者甚至，或者甚至哪怕是我的夜晚和我的警察记录不会无缘无故地处于危险之中。所以那种高高在上的非个人、不友好的政府的感觉非常糟糕。
over you is pretty terrible. George Canning is not an advocate of stop and frisk. In fact, all the way back in 1982, he foresaw the possibility that giving police wide discretion could lead to abuse. In our interview, I read him a passage from that article that is proven to be prescient. We might agree that certain behavior makes one person more undesirable than another, but how do we ensure that age or skin color or national origin or harmless mannerisms will not also become the basis for distinguishing the undesirable from the desirable? How do we ensure in short that the police do not become the agents of neighborhood bigotry? We can offer no holy satisfactory answer to this important question.
乔治·坎宁并不是“拦截搜身”的倡导者。事实上，早在1982年，他就预见到了赋予警察广泛自由裁量权可能导致滥用的可能性。在我们的采访中，我向他朗读了那篇文章中的一段话，事实证明这段话具有先见之明。我们或许可以同意某种行为使某个人比另一个人更不可取，但我们如何确保年龄、肤色、国籍或无害的癖好不会也成为区分不可取者与可取者的基础呢？简而言之，我们如何确保警察不成为社区偏见的代理人？对于这个重要问题，我们无法提供完全令人满意的答案。
Yeah, that's a loaded statement. And it's something that I've struggled with. In August of 2013, a Federal District Court found that New York's stop and frisk policy was unconstitutional because of the way it singled out young, black, and Hispanic men. Later that year, New York elected its first liberal mayor in 20 years. Build a Blasio celebrated the end of stop and frisk. for civil liberties. We are all hungry for an approach that acknowledges we are stronger and safer as a city when police and residents work hand in hand. But he did not do away with broken windows. In fact, he reappointed Rudy Giuliani's police commissioner, Bill Bratton.
是的，这是一个很有分量（带有偏见）的陈述。这也是我一直在挣扎的事情。2013年8月，联邦地区法院裁定，纽约的“拦截搜身”政策违宪，因为它排挤了年轻的黑人和西班牙裔男子。同年晚些时候，纽约选出了20年来第一位自由派市长。比尔·德布拉西奥庆祝“拦截搜身”的结束。为了公民自由。我们都渴望有一种方法，承认当警察和居民携手合作时，作为一个城市，我们会更强大、更安全。但他并没有废除“破窗”。事实上，他重新任命了鲁迪·朱利安尼的警察局长比尔·布拉顿。
It is a great day for New York City because I am proud to announce that I am appointing Bill Bratton as the next police commissioner of the city of New York. Just seven months after taking over again as the head of New York's police department, Bill Bratton's use of broken windows tactics came under fresh scrutiny. In this video, shot on a bystander cell phone on a sunny July day in New York City in 2014, a man is standing on the sidewalk between two police officers. Several more officers are just outside of the frame. The cops are asking the man whether he was selling loose cigarettes, a misdemeanor. The man is visibly and audibly upset.
对纽约市来说这是伟大的一天，因为我很荣幸地宣布，我将任命比尔·布拉顿为纽约市下一任警察局长。就在重新接管纽约警察局仅仅七个月后，比尔·布拉顿对“破窗”战术的使用受到了新的审查。在这段于2014年阳光明媚的7月某日在纽约市由路人用手机拍摄的视频中，一名男子正站在两名警察之间的人行道上。画面外还有几名警察。警察正在询问这名男子是否在兜售散装香烟（这是一种轻罪）。这名男子明显且发出声音地感到沮丧。
This is not the first time he has been questioned by police. And then the officers tackle him. They bring him to the ground while restraining him with a chokehold, a practice that is banned in New York City. The man in the video is Eric Garner. He's African-American and his name has become synonymous with the growing distrust between police and African-American communities. He died not long after the interaction you just heard. Commissioner Bill Bratton found himself on the fire from the media not only about Eric Garner's death, but the entire philosophy of broken windows. Here he is talking with CBS News anchor Maurice Dubois in 2014. Commissioner, critics are blaming your broken windows policy. Here he is talking with CBS News anchor Maurice Dubois in 2014. We are not targeting communities to call out, we are targeting behavior in the behavior is.
这不是他第一次被警察盘问。然后警察扑倒了他。他们把他按倒在地，同时用扼喉法制服他，这种做法在纽约市是被禁的。视频中的男子是埃里克·加纳。他是非裔美国人，他的名字已经成为警察与非裔美国人社区之间日益增长的不信任的代名词。他在你刚刚听到的互动后不久就去世了。警察局长比尔·布拉顿不仅因埃里克·加纳的死而遭到媒体的猛烈抨击，而且因整个“破窗”哲学而遭到抨击。这是他在2014年与CBS新闻主播莫里斯·杜布瓦的对话。局长，批评者正在指责你的破窗政策。这是他在2014年与CBS新闻主播莫里斯·杜布瓦的对话。我们不是在针对某个社区进行指责，我们是在针对行为，行为就是……
For George Kelly, this was not the end that he had hoped for. As a researcher, he is one of the few whose ideas have left the academy and spread like wildfire. But once politicians and the media fed and loved with his idea, they took it to places that he never intended and could not control. When during the 1990s, broken windows was a hot ticket item. I would occasionally read in the newspaper something like, a new chief comes in and says, I just read broken windows and I'm going to implement broken windows tomorrow. I won't repeat the magic words that go through my mind
对乔治·凯林来说，这并不是他所希望的结局。作为一名研究人员，他是极少数其思想走出学术界并像野火一样蔓延的人之一。但一旦政客和媒体喜欢上他的想法，他们就把它带到了他从未预料到也无法控制的地方。在20世纪90年代“破窗”是个热门话题时。我偶尔会在报纸上看到诸如“新局长上任，说我刚读了《破窗》，我明天就要实施破窗”之类的话。我不会重复脑海中闪过的那些魔法般的词汇，
because we're on the air. But I would listen to that with dismay. Dismay because he worried that many officials were so enamored with the simplicity of the broken windows metaphor that they were not willing to stop and think about the nuances. He worried that officers who hadn't received enough training were being asked to exercise discretion and make complex judgments on the very high pressure. And so, do I worry about the implementation about broken windows a whole lot? Yes, I worry about the implementation of order maintenance because it can be done very badly. It's to the point now where I wonder if we should back away from the metaphor of broken
因为我们正在直播。但我会怀着沮丧的心情听着。沮丧是因为他担心许多官员对“破窗”隐喻的简单性如此着迷，以至于他们不愿意停下来思考其中的细微差别。他担心那些没有接受足够培训的警官被要求在巨大压力下行使自由裁量权并做出复杂的判断。所以，我非常担心“破窗”的实施吗？是的，我担心秩序维护的实施，因为它可以被执行得很糟糕。现在的情况是，我甚至在想我们是否应该摆脱“破窗”这个隐喻。
windows. Broken windows was a powerful metaphor. Jim and I used it. We didn't know how powerful it was going to be. It simplified. It was easy to communicate. A lot of people got it as a result of the metaphor. It was attractive.
破窗是一个强有力的隐喻。吉姆和我使用了它。我们不知道它会如此强大。它被简化了。它易于沟通。由于这个隐喻，很多人理解了它。它很有吸引力。
And it carried us for a long time. But as you know, metaphors can wear out and become stale. These days, the consensus among social scientists is that broken windows likely did have modest effects on crime But few believe it caused the 60 or 70 percent decline in violent crime that it's often credited with Despite all the evidence broken windows continues to be popular Bernhard Hart Court says there's a reason for that It's a simple story that
它支撑了我们很长时间。但如你所知，隐喻会磨损并变得陈旧。如今，社会科学家之间的共识是，“破窗”可能确实对犯罪产生了适度的影响，但很少有人相信它导致了通常归功于它的60%或70%的暴力犯罪下降。尽管有种种证据，“破窗”仍然很受欢迎。伯恩哈德·哈考特说这是有原因的。这是一个简单的故事，
people can latch onto and that then is a lot more pleasant to live with than the complexities of life. The fact is that crime dropped in America dramatically from the 1990s and that there aren't really good, good clean nation-wide explanations for it. The story of broken windows is a story of our fascination with easy fixes and seductive theories. Once an idea like that takes hold, it's nearly impossible to get the genie back in the bottle. This episode of the Hidden Brain Podcast was produced by Maggie Penman and edited by
人们可以紧抓不放，这比生活的复杂性要好过得多。事实是，自20世纪90年代以来，美国的犯罪率急剧下降，并且对此并没有真正好、干净的全国性解释。破窗的故事是我们对简单解决办法和诱人理论的迷恋的故事。一旦这样的想法扎根，就几乎不可能把妖怪再装回瓶子里了。本期《隐藏的大脑》播客由玛吉·彭曼制作，珍妮·施密特
Jenny Schmidt. Our team includes Brenna Clar and Raina Cohen. Our supervising producer is Tara Boyle. Our unsung hero this week is Jenna Weissberman. She's a producer who used to work at NPR and she played an important role in getting the Hidden Brain podcast off the ground. Jenna contributed a lot of reporting to this episode. Over the next few weeks, we're going to bring you other stories exploring how race, immigration
剪辑。我们的团队包括布雷纳·克拉尔和雷娜·科恩。我们的主管制作人是塔拉·博伊尔。我们本周的无名英雄是珍娜·韦斯伯曼。她是一位曾在NPR工作过的制作人，她在让《隐藏的大脑》播客顺利起步方面发挥了重要作用。珍娜为本期节目贡献了大量的报道。在接下来的几周里，我们将为您带来其他故事，探讨种族、移民
and religion intersect with politics, policing and the media. Next week, we look at new research that asks whether a psychological test can predict how police will interact with people of color. Please subscribe to the podcast to make sure you get that episode. We're looking forward to having you join us. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
和宗教如何与政治、警务和媒体交织在一起。下周，我们将关注一项新的研究，该研究询问心理测试是否能够预测警察将如何与有色人种互动。请订阅本播客，以确保您能收听到那一集。我们期待您的加入。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。